let's just show these uh live pictures
of
the ambulance uh just actually came in a
few seconds ago of an ambulance arriving
in berlin believed to be carrying the
russian opposition leader
alexey navalny who's been transported
from
russia with a suspected case of uh
poisoning
although medics in russia said they
found no evidence of that those
supporters are insisting that they
believe that he was poisoned while
at the airport in russia through a cup
of tea that
he drank so those are the latest
pictures of him arriving
at the hospital in berlin to resume
treatment there
we'll keep you up to date on his
situation throughout the course of the
day